let's let's start good morning everyone
um it's a pleasure to be here again with
all of you at the next
session of our workshop on program
synthesis
uh our first speaker today will be
rishab thing who works at google brain
rishab
got his phd at mit and
after that he worked at microsoft
research and became
one of the very early pioneers in using
machine learning
for program synthesis or vice versa
program synthesis for machine learning
both of these actually and
i know he has been doing exciting things
recently at google brain
some of those he may be able to tell us
about some of them perhaps not yet
but regardless we really look forward to
seeing your recent results reshop thank
you for joining us
thanks a lot raspberry for the kind
introduction and thanks for inviting me
today i was thinking about just talking
about some of the more recent work
we've been working towards neural
program synthesis
uh so okay let's let's get started um
great so so basically we've seen uh in
last few years
uh lots of tremendous progress in in
search based program synthesis trying to
scale up synthesis to tackle
larger and larger search spaces and
we've had lots and lots of successes in
terms of both
constraint based synthesis uh deductive
reasoning
uh specialized algorithm and and
even uh enumerative search we can now
scale up with lots of new ideas
so so that's been actually quite quite
good uh but one
challenge still with these techniques is
that they can't really
even for some of the modest complex
programs
uh these techniques the search base
quickly becomes too large and we're not
able to scale to or even generalized to
do um larger classes of programs
so so for to tackle this challenge
actually we've been looking at
if you want to step back and think about
how human program is
so that's actually an interesting
example where we have
very strong evidence that human
programmers we can write very complex
programs we can write
we can take specification in in many
different formats
and ambiguous thing and then generate
code that satisfy the specification
and and if we look back a little bit
more about how we are able to solve a
lot of these
problems uh there's some notion of some
logical reasoning we have to do we have
to understand what the problem is
how to solve it then it's also the case
that not
we don't actually begin with as being a
super programmer to begin with we first
learn we go through courses we learn
programming
read books then over time actually we
get better as we write more and more
programs
and finally actually uh nowadays
especially we don't really learn
uh we write programs from scratch for
many of these cases we actually use
samples from lots of other places so uh
so some of the work i'll talk about
today we're trying to see can we get
inspiration from this mechanism of how
human programmers are able to take
complicated specifications and write
programs can we build systems that can
leverage
similar type of reasoning similar type
of mechanisms to
to help scale up these synthesis process
and also one thing i wanted to um
also contrast a little bit with some of
the techniques will be
seen today compared to search based
methods
so i was trying to figure out some ways
where we can
contrast the two sets of techniques so
so the first thing
is basically what i'm calling intuition
here
which is more about um trying to write
programs without needing to enumerate
um so so there's actually one difference
uh we can see when we as humans programs
we don't really search
for all possible programs and then
rightful but actually we have this
intuitive reasoning
uh behind the scenes that we use to
write programs
the second thing is we um unlike search
based systems that are typically static
we have one system
that we use for synthesis again and
again whereas as human programmers we
we are not static in the sense we as we
learn
new things new concepts as we write more
programs we get better over time
so they also have this characteristics
of improving over time
then also as we saw earlier actually
as human programmers we can write
understand specifications in many
different formats
which is unlike typically search based
systems that take
specification in in a given format
um and then finally actually we also
have this capability of
when we are trying to write a bigger
program uh
we don't just solve the whole problem at
once we
break it down make the problem down into
sub problems and then we
write programs for some problems and
then we learn to compose them
um yeah and then finally actually one
more characteristic which is interesting
uh is this notion of being completely
correct
uh so typically search based systems we
we try to generate programs that are
uh exactly correct with respect to
specifications
but i'm sure many of us have experienced
this as well it's it's very
seldom the case that we write the
correct program in first go
we we actually typically write a program
we find issues with it
uh or actually then we correct it so so
also this notion that it's okay to make
mistakes
and then learn from mistakes rather than
generating full program sequence
so so for this talk i'm hoping to give
very brief um overviews of some of the
techniques we are using and try to
connect it to some of these ideas
as we go uh in the top great so let's
start with
uh this first contrast about intuitions
versus enumeration
and essentially what i mean here is that
um
rather than using lots and lots of
compute lots of resources to
search for a program what if we take a
step back and say
i'm going to take limited resources
because because that's how actually
as humans also we we have some evidence
that yeah
we don't really enumerate programs when
writing
so how do we bring that type of notion
in
in in generating programs so for this
actually
and also for other systems i'll use an
example
uh like this so so there's a system uh
called smartphone now in google sheets
which allows users to write
improper examples of the desired thing
they would want their data to
be transformed to and then it learns
programs in the sheets language
that are consistent with the examples
so so so one general philosophy
will see actually uh to to learn
programs and
various different settings as uh is this
framework
where the basic idea is that we're going
to use
lots and lots of data to learn this
intuitive style
reasoning for generate programs
so the basic idea is something like this
we start with a programming language
let's say for smartphone we start with
sheets programming language or for
tensorflow it could be a tensorflow
language
then we're going to generate lots and
lots of data uh
in this in in this programming language
by sampling random programs
and then we generate specification for
that in this case it would be improper
examples
and then we have paired data set we have
input examples and programs
for which we're going to train these
models and hopefully these models are
going to capture some of this intuitive
reasoning
to perform um the code generation and
testing
so what we do here we start with this
programming language and
we generate random programs so here a
couple of random programs
we just sampled we generate random
inputs we can run these programs on the
inputs to get outputs and now we get
this pairs of examples saying
here are input examples and here
programs corresponding to those examples
uh and then at test time the hope is if
the models have learned the right thing
they can generalize to even real-world
data that users want to perform
in such cases so so that's the overall
framework now we have lots of choices of
how are we going to implement
the the uh the architectures to to
import these
specifications and programs and and
here's one example
that we used before uh which was more of
an encoder decoder architecture
where we first have improper example
encodings
and in this case these are simple um
let's say lstms that can
treat inputs and outputs as sequence of
characters so we first encode input
using a bi-directional scheme
which then is used to condition the
encoding of the output
its string in the example and then we
finally have a decoder that
learns a distribution over programs
conditioned on both input and output
encoding
uh so so this way we can encode one
example similarly we can encode
multiple examples user is providing and
finally we do some type of cooling to
learn a consistent
distribution of programs that is
consistent over all the examples
so so there are multiple choices we can
have here this was one particular
uh encoding we used and it turned out
actually it
worked quite well it got about 92
percent
um generalization accuracy which was in
fact even higher than the
uh hand coded version we had earlier
it's uh like a
manual search and gotten uh and which
was kind of
quite quite interesting to see that uh
first at least these domains the models
are able to learn
um this form of intuitive reasoning
uh to to be able to generate programs
for unseen examples of testing
uh and one more side exam side note here
uh
in the experiments we were trying was we
can also contrast this approach little
bit with
this notion of differentiable
programming where we make
we take these programming languages and
make it all continuous uh differentiated
so we can do gradient descent
directly in the program space uh but one
thing we found that
actually doing radiant descent in the in
the continuous space
wasn't as effective as actually using
the
using the learning to uh perform this
uh kind of intuitive search over
symbolic space
so that was a kind of side experiment
but it's interesting to see that
actually it's
important to have symbolic grounding in
in a programming language rather than
making everything continuous
now now the second component here is
actually we want these systems to
improve over time
i won't have too much time to go into 2h
details here but
but even in the previous system actually
we will see that since we are training
these models again and again as new data
is coming in
or we are generalizing them to slightly
different dsms on top of what they
already have
so we do see this type of transfer where
we don't have to train these systems
again and again from scratch we can just
leverage
what we have trained and which captures
this notion of as humans also when we
learn programming we don't just
forget everything we have learned in the
past we can keep building on top
i'll be happy to talk about it later in
the q a if this time
about this as well now the next next
part was
understanding multimodal specifications
uh and for this i'm going to use this
example called tf coding
uh so df query is the system where
it's similar to smart phil where users
can give
introductory examples of tensor
transformations they want to perform in
tensorflow
uh but the interesting part here is that
in addition to examples they can also
specify their intent
in natural language so here's an example
uh taken from stack overflow where
a user specifies uh a task they have in
in english
and then they also give an example to
clarify what sort of tasks
they have in mind uh and actually this
was a question for which there was no
answer
for i think almost two days and when we
ran the system uh actually this
uh answer was generated by tf coded
and uh there are many such uh problems
for which
df coder can generate uh exam uh
generate answers which are
which are quite uh quite some uh similar
to how
human experts would write uh so the
basic idea of the system is that
we have a natural language specification
and then we have some important examples
and then we give this type of
specification to the system
and then the system comes up with a
program uh that
is hopefully uh that's guaranteed to be
consistent with the examples and also
uh likely consistent with the with the
natural language specification
um so so the basic architecture is
similar to
robust film we saw earlier where we have
we're going to build these models that
can
ingest examples to distributions over
programs
uh one in interesting thing here is that
we also have natural language
specification in addition to examples
uh but the nice part about having these
uh
learning based mechanisms is that um for
for these actually we can just have one
more encoder and we can keep
the whole pipeline similar to as before
so so that's the nice thing about having
a learning based system that we can
add new and new modalities or
specifications
uh just as easily uh in our synthesis
process
now one challenge uh unlike that unlike
improper examples is that we can't
synthetically generate lots and lots of
uh natural language we can but it won't
be very realistic
and it won't be um the distribution
won't match the kind of distribution we
see
at this time from users so for
learning a language to api distribution
part
uh we for this work we leverage the
documentation
that these apis have uh and then we do
some
pfidf based cosine similarity to say
given a natural language statement
which apis are most likely to be likely
to be relevant and useful
so once we have these two distributions
from examples in natural language to
events
we can then perform this type of
intuitive uh search we were
looking at earlier where we have
programs of
different apis a composition of
different aps and we can guide them
using
using these weights and distributions
and and and again here also in some of
the preliminary experiments we were
doing we did see that
not only not only um by adding this
learning component we can
improve search based systems but it can
also
be much faster compared to just doing
doing search
uh great so so this was an example of
multi-modal uh specifications now let me
quickly talk about
uh last two uh contrast points i had uh
one was about
like we typically don't solve these
problems in one go we usually break down
the problem into smaller parts
and then learn to compose so for this
i'm going to use an example for for
latent programming
so here the basic idea is given uh given
a similar problem let's say the problem
we were looking at smartphone or
robust film before where we have input
examples
and i would like a program that is
consistent with the examples
so in those previous books we were
trying to go directly from
from examples to programs or
distributions over programs
but here um
we wanted to explore actually can we can
we
have this additional bias in the
architecture where
we force the model to perform some type
of
decomposition and then solve some
problems and then learn to
compose again so just to give a concrete
example let's say this was a program
some spreadsheet user wanted to perform
and if you look at a program actually
the program gets first number and then
gets first capital second capital third
capital so
if we look at the program there's a lot
of actual similarity in the sense
this notion of get capital is is
kind of getting repeated again and again
three times
and then there's a constant string as
well that is repeated
so so rather than having the model
generate full programs from examples
uh we now have this additional bias
which we're calling it
kind of latent uh latent discrete latent
tokens
so now what the model does it first maps
the examples to this
discrete latent space where each latent
token is
trying to capture a sub problem and then
for
each individual sub problem we can ask
the model to generate
generate the concrete program in the
language we would like to
we would like to generate now one
challenge with this approach is that
uh we don't really typically have the
intermediate
latents when we are when we are trained
these models we just have imperfect
examples and programs so for that
we came up with this architecture where
we first
have during training we have all these
low level programs
and we try to quantize them we train
these
discrete vaes that try to
come up with a discrete latent space uh
which tries to explain the low level
program so it's trying to learn
commonalities of common sub problems
that are present in lots and lots of
programs
so that defines our latent space
then what happens is uh we add this
latent space as as an additional uh
additional mechanism for the decoder to
decode before decoding the full program
so we start with examples
then we first map the examples to this
latent space that has been learned
using discrete values and then we use
this discrete latency
to uh to again um uh
go back to the go back to the final
concrete uh
concrete program domain using uh
another set of decoding so the nice
thing about this approach is that
in addition to giving uh shaping the
the intermediate latency space we we can
also now perform two level
two level intuitive search so rather
than just performing this intuitive
search towards the end of the decoding
now we have one more space which i'm
calling this discrete latency
and and the hope is that there
in that space the model can perform
reasoning
at the at the decomposition level it can
learn many different ways to decompose
the problem
and then the in and then the lower level
of search can actually do
concrete symbolic um generation of
programs
uh and yeah again in some of our initial
results we saw that having this discrete
bottleneck in in the middle
that captures some of these higher level
sub problems
allows the model to learn programs of
much longer links
as well as now now we can
actually perform reasoning at two levels
one at this higher level of
abstraction and uh and then one at the
lower level
so now let's say uh if i want to search
for
for a program give given a budget let's
say i can only do hundred price
so i can i can distribute my hundred
tries to save let me do ten tries at the
at the higher level and then let's let
me do ten tries
at the lower level so we can we can
distribute this budget
but yeah this is one way where we can
impose more structure in the label
speeds to encourage
these models to learn um
learn to decompose and and
and solve these problems more more
efficiently
great so so let me come to the final
final point uh on
on can we go beyond just um forcing the
synthesizers to generate always correct
programs
and for this i'm going to use this
example of differentiating fixing
and the basic idea is actually quite
simple so let's say i'm given some
examples
like in smartphone and i generate a
program
now um now let's say this program is
uh so so my initial task was to get
first capital
and last word but let's say the model
has learned to get first capital
and second word which works for most of
the inputs but for second input it
doesn't
produce the right answer so now
uh so usually what would what would we
do in previous approaches is we would
generate lots and lots of programs
and we would just do this type of
generate and filter approach we would
run the programs and see which ones work
and return it
return the one that works back to the
user
but if you think about how humans might
go about
fixing this problem is that actually we
can we can look at the output that the
model has produced
and then use that output and current
program to come up with an improvement
to the
previous program so rather than rather
than discarding that program and
starting approach
we can say that i have a good starting
point and let me
come up with some of the
changes to this program that will fix
the output
so in this case what would happen is we
would feed these examples and the
original programs through differential
fixing
and it would uh it would then say that
rather than using second one i have to
use last word to
to fix this mistake uh and in terms of
architecture
it's similar to robert's field in the
sense we start with some encoding of the
examples
we generate uh we map it to a label
space
and from that we can generate a program
we then run this program
on the examples and now we get doubles
of
original examples and the new output
that the program is produced
and we feed it back we encoded back
these
three three tuples back to the label
space
and now we decode it again so so the
hope is that
since we are mapping all of these tuples
back to the same latencies
in theory we can apply this fixes step
multiple times so we can keep
applying the fixes until we get to the
right proof
uh and here again actually in the
experiments we saw that
having this differentiable fixer
mechanism uh allows the model to
uh to not only make changes uh
so typically if you look at beam search
beam search would typically make changes
towards the end of the program but now
with differentiable fixer we can fix
mistakes
even in the middle of the program or
before as well as it can make many more
changes to make the
model correct of program current rather
than rather than making small changes
what green search does
yeah so i guess briefly i just wanted to
show you some ideas
about uh how we can take inspiration
from
how human programmers um
write programs by breaking down the
problems or or
doing this type of intuitive reasoning
or fixing mistakes
and here's some pointers to some of the
work
we're trying to uh we've been doing in
this space to see
which techniques my uh and which types
of architectures might
you might be able to build to perform uh
these types of human-like reasoning but
i think these are just some very early
steps
there's lots and lots of interesting
problems here
both in terms of what are the best
architectures to encode
specifications and programs how do we
build architectures that can perform
logical reasoning
and and also in terms of feedback as
humans
we learn from textbooks we learn from
great teachers who teaches programming
um how do we incorporate
even richer feedback than the kind of
feedback i showed today which was
very low level uh usually this from data
um and then finally how do we apply
these techniques to go beyond
uh these small pro custom languages but
to
do more real world languages there's
lots of lots of exciting directions
uh great so this was briefly some things
i want to talk about i'll be happy to
take some questions or
any other questions people might have
thank you rishab this was great thank
you for the nice talk we do have
exactly five minutes for questions so
people should just
type them in the chat or better yet turn
on the microphone and
speak up
i i could start uh richard could you
could you tell us a bit more about the
sub problem identification um
that was the part four i'd like to
understand a bit better how
yeah this was this was the interesting
slide
uh how you actually identify the sub
problems
is it is it relying on the fact that the
output
includes parts of the input or is that
not the requirement
for the latent scheme to work
yeah i think energy uh again there's
actually lots of
ways we can capture the sub problem so
in this case um
in this domain uh in this domain of text
processing yeah there's some overlap in
inputs and outputs so so it makes it
easy to see the decomposition
uh in some other domains it may not be
as apparent but hopefully
hopefully the architecture that we're
using to come up with
some problems hopefully that's going to
generalize as well
so the basic idea of the basic
assumption we're making here
is that um we have these
low-level programs we want the model to
generalize to to generate
now rather than generating each
low-level program token by token
what is actually new about some concept
so we may we're making an assumption
that there exists
some form of higher order higher order
functions we can think about
or or sub functions that are generating
these low level programs
so this latent space is capturing that
assumption that
can i map my low level programs into
this higher level abstraction
such that can i explain low level
programs as compositions of these
higher level labels and and in this case
actually yeah so
so we did see some interesting uh
aspects after training that for example
token 36 is this high level latent that
captures this notion of
capitals uh even though there's there's
like
different sub lower level programs first
capital second capital third capital
but it's capturing some notion of
capital followed by dot
uh so yeah so so it's it's one way these
models are learning to
capture some higher order reasoning for
these low level low level
tokens i see and then those those
latents are
learned completely using an auto encoder
style
or yeah yeah so in the beginning uh we
train
between this auto encoder uh we have a
discrete bottleneck there to ensure that
uh the auto encoder learns like a
discrete uh token space
uh and then they are also fine-tuned
little bit during
during uh training with examples
thank you other questions
okay if uh we do have one minute left i
uh perhaps we should move to the next
speaker
thank you rishabh for the nice talk this
will be all
recorded and so other people will be
able to
record it and post it see later and uh
thanks so much